a slaughterhouse in Essex secret cameras
film three different workers using the
pigs faces to stub out their cigarettes
chill meets claims to be proud of high
welfare but these images obtained
exclusively by Sky News seem to show
otherwise injured pigs were forced to
crawl into the stump egg one is dragged
by its ears incompetent use of the stun
electrodes cause the animals to suffer
further others are beaten for no reason
with bats multiple breaches of the
welfare laws but all captured using
fixed cameras that have been secretly
installed by trespassing and because of
this unlawful entries of the property
welfare group animal aide who obtained
this footage have been told it can't be
used to prosecute the individuals who
are clearly seen abusing the animals
under the previous government deaf or
were bringing prosecutions against all
number of slaughterhouses and many
slaughterhouse workers for similar
breaches but then there was a change of
government change at the head of Defra
and suddenly all those cases were
dropped and no more will be brought now
we can't really understand why this
would be the case a legal advice is that
the footage is good it could be used as
evidence in court in a letter the Food
Standards Agency says Defra is not
prepared to commence prosecution
proceedings where the initial allegation
is based on CCTV footage gained without
the consent of the relevant food
business operator Defra didn't want to
comment on camera but they do say that
they wouldn't use illegal footage in
court because they feel they wouldn't
have much chance of a successful
prosecution and yet there are many
examples where illegally obtained
footage has led to successful
convictions only last month Glen Brown
was found guilty of animal cruelty one
of dozens of successful prosecutions by
the RSPB thanks to secret filming on
private land he was caught setting an
illegal cage trap
and these farm workers in Norfolk were
also punished thanks to film from
trespassing cameras there are some cases
where what you see is so extraordinary
awful and compelling evidence that
perhaps it's easier then to use a one
arts that would be of course to have
CCTV in these places and then you've got
lawfully obtained material and as long
as it's watched and monitored and acted
on promptly the Food Standards Agency
say two workers have lost their licenses
as a result of the footage while chill
meets told us they can't be certain the
footage is from their premises but say
they've asked essex police to
investigate whether it was obtained
unlawfully Jason Farrell's Sky News